[Music]
so idealism is a metaphysic of
experience and the obstacle to
understanding what i'm going to try give
you an idea of today try and explain
the obstacle to understanding it is the
various misunderstandings around the
notion of experience that have arisen
in the last hundred years as i see it
because
materialism has been the dominant
metaphysics and also in the last few
decades when the influence of
materialism is beginning to wane i think
again
these uh misunderstandings are prevalent
so in order to understand the kind of
idealism which i will be talking about
you need to forget a bunch of things
okay forget the idea of experiences in
bubbles coming out of your head like in
a cartoon okay
just for the moment forget the idea of
consciousness being a mystery which is
currently being unraveled by
investigation into our brain
neuroscience etc
forget the idea of consciousness spread
around the universe in places you'd
never expect you know electrons etc
and most importantly
forget about the idea of idealism as
making any challenge to how you see
things in your ordinary everyday life
because in a way that's the point of
this kind of idealism
it doesn't challenge that and it can't
unlike the other dominant metaphysics
such as materialism dualism and psyches
pan psychiatrism which it seems to be do
continually challenge how we look at
things in everyday life the kind of
idealism
that i'm talking about can't do that
it's not a difficult or
counter-intuitive view it's not remotely
mystical and it seems to me that once
you see it it makes an easy addition to
your common sense and appears clears
away many apparent mysteries
so i want to
begin by just making a distinction which
i want you to always bear in mind
between
explanation
and reality and i've got one of my
holiday snaps on the uh on the screen
here this is me in wales this year and
i'm by this ancient dolmen in wales
built in about 3500 bc and when we i was
very impressed by this and when i got
there i thought how did they do that
right it's huge that that that capstone
is enormous five meters long right how
do they get it up there so i looked at
my phone and i got an explanation okay
apparently they put little stones
underneath and then leave it up a little
bit and then they put some more stones
up and then leave it a bit more then
when they got to the height where they
could put the columns in they took the
stones away um
so note that you know getting an
explanation tells you how to do
something
in a way it takes you away from the
reality right you're imagining these
possibilities you know maybe i could do
this with a bunch of people or you're
imagining these people in the past right
but the reality is they're straight
before you okay an explanation quite
often does this it it's it's a matter of
telling you how to do something you know
like somebody saw thunder and lightning
and uh maybe they were given the
explanation without zeus throwing his
thunderbolts okay or in the modern day
and age you'd be told it's to do with a
rapid expansion of air next to the
next to the lightning and of course
those kind of explanations have allowed
us to do things right they're giving us
insight which allows us to create
technology etc
but nevertheless it seems to me that
what's happened now
is we've been become so impressed by the
power of our explanations that we forget
the actual
reality right
the reality
is this right now it's what you're
experiencing right which you understand
in a certain way your understanding of
is the explanation but there shouldn't
be any question about what the reality
is okay it's what you call experience
look at some great apes in the zoo
gorillas grounded tanks chimpanzees and
bonobos
the fifth kind of great tape is the
human being the others are behind bars
because we are smarter
much much smarter
at one time we only had sticks and
stones but that was still more than the
other animals had
they had only tooth and claw
now we have
intercontinental nuclear missiles
we can destroy anything we please
she gets very enthusiastic there yeah i
was a materialist when i started out in
philosophy i can't say i gave it an
awful lot of thought it just struck me
as a sort of no-brainer obviously
reality is as physical science describes
it and um
the problem seemed to me to be created
by that picture so i did my phd on how
the brain relates to consciousness and
you know sort of standard question for
analytic philosophers these days and the
reason i went into that issue is because
i didn't think any of the current
answers to that question from
materialist made sense i didn't doubt
materialism for a second
but now
i don't think any account of that is
going to work because i think it's
thinking about experience in
the wrong way and what started to change
my mind
is to just really see the separation
between something like science and
metaphysics right there are many
metaphysical interpretations of science
and materialism is an ancient one okay
it's an ancient one that goes back to
ancient greece and also ancient india
the first materials that we know
anything about
was democritus
and right from the beginning and when
you see the spread of the influence of
materials of to the current day and age
the appeal of materialism has always
been its association with a certain
political agenda an anti-religious
agenda now i'm an atheist okay but
nevertheless this fact makes me
suspicious about the truth of
metaphysical
theory um so democritus thought that the
gods don't have anything to do with us
right they pay no attention to human
beings so um religious institutions were
a bit of a rip-off right creating these
anxieties in people as they were
praying
um
now
when you come to the enlightenment in
the modern era
materialism gets a new lease of life why
well the background to it seems to have
been a lot of dissatisfaction with
religion and religious institutions
because the religious wars have been
going on
and then the enlightenment there's uh
kind of a manifesto for
building heaven on earth rather than
waiting for god to give us heaven okay
let's use science and technology to
create a better world
well in a sense that's what happened we
saw um you know in the 20th century we
saw a technological explosion which has
you know
massively changed the amount of the
number of people in the world the
standard of life that people have and i
think that people have falsely
assumed that this
vindicated a you know an ancient
metaphysical interpretation of science i
don't think
um
it does anything of the sort it seems to
me that any
decent metaphysical account ought to be
compatible with what contemporary
science is saying at the moment um
and if you actually look at the you know
i think i think materialist philosophy
which has become a kind of background
theme that people don't even recognize
as philosophy and mistake as if it's the
same thing as science has had a huge
influence on the world i mean you could
see
the the you know standoff between
communism and capitalism in the 20th
century is a disagreement about how to
extract the atoms from our environment
and put them back together to you know
give us all a good standard of life
so those are the kind of
essentially if you're talking about the
metaphysics the rational reasons that i
think it is has come to be dominant
basically forgetting what philosophy is
and forgetting you know
and thinking it's the same thing as
science and technology
if you actually look at what
um
a materialist has to say in order to
persuade other philosophers of their
view well right from the beginning of
the materials relations in the 1950s it
focused on conscious experience
because there's something very odd about
saying that an experience or a pain or a
thought can be something physical right
how can it have a size and a shape right
um it doesn't seem to make sense right
an experience is there just for me
whereas an object is out there in the
world
and the way that materialist tried to
deal with this issue is well i mean any
materialist must ultimately identify
experiences no matter how much technical
apparatus they put around it if
everything is physical then ultimately
experiences and thoughts must be
physical as well so there must be some
kind of identity
and they went straight for that
particular way of looking at it to start
with but the pro
so how can there be an identity between
two things which seem to have different
properties right well what they say is
it's really just two interpretations
right so it is like you can interpret
something as a statue or a lump of clay
you're interpreting a break it has a
brain state or as an experience
well there's two problems with that um
reasons it won't work one the idea of
interpreting presupposes consciousness
right a rock or a chair doesn't
interpret anything so you can't lean on
the notion of consciousness to explain
how consciousness can be something
physical even if you think you can get
around that
okay the bigger problem is one of those
interpretations must be wrong it must be
incorrect right because the correct
interpretation is as a brain state okay
if i interpret that as both a screen and
a cat okay which seem very different
then the cat which i'm imagining doesn't
really exist
um
so this led many philosophers to um
to deny the existence of experience or
say that it's a kind of illusion it's a
you know the evidence is illusory in
some sense
um but the problem with that
is if experience is illusory in some way
okay we shouldn't trust it's a
misconception of
of physical reality
then well our whole world view is built
on this misinterpretation right the
whole world of science so there's no
reason to believe materialism in the
first place
and amazingly democritus back in ancient
greece was aware of this problem he kind
of split his mind into his thought and
his sensation
and he says poor thought do you take
your warrant from us and then overthrow
us our overthrow is your fault he
thought the materialism led to a kind of
skepticism
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well
as i've been trying to suggest you i
think that technological success did
most of the work in making materialism a
force in our world within academic
philosophy it was mainly by arguing
against dualism a kind of
misrepresentation of dualism okay so the
jeweler's view would be there there are
reality is sort of split between the
physical world
and the experiential and conscious world
in some way they interact um
more recently there's been a resurgence
of pan psychiatrism which is actually a
very ancient view in which in some sense
everything is is conscious or you know
consciousness is to be found in
fundamental physical reality um
now people have problems with both of
these because they seem to have
counter-intuitive consequences i'm not
going to talk about them in detail
because
i think they're a good illustration
of
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you